gerade gehen Hunderttausende auf die
Straße gegen Rechtsextremismus und
Fremdenfeindlichkeit eine demobewegung
wie sie Deutschland lange nicht erlebt
hat ich bin sehr sehr selten auf
Demonstrationen aber ich glaube das ist
heute ein Punkt wo man einfach mal dabei
sein sollte und zeigen sollte dass man
auch gegen diese Entwicklung in
Deutschland ist unsere Kinder sollen in
einem Land aufwachsen wo ja jeder sein
darf wie wie ist und wo die Türen offen
stehen die aktuellen Enthüllungen rund
um ein geheimtreff in Potzdam und um den
dort diskutierten Plan massenhaft
Menschen mit ausländischen Wurzeln zu
vertreiben diese Enthüllungen haben
offenbar ein Ventil geöffnet die Sorge
vieler ist dass da gerade etwas ins
Rutschen gerätt in Deutschland und ganz
konkret wird diese Sorge mit dem Blick
auf diesen September was passiert da bei
den drei Wahlen in Thüringen Brandenburg
und Sachsen die ostwahlen sind in
Deutschland mit Sicherheit das
wichtigste politische Ereignis in diesem
Jahr ja und in der Politik sind gerade
sehr viele sehr nervös wenn Sie auf
diese Wahlen schauen es geht um mehr als
nur die Frage wie Ergebnisse sind es
geht um Demokratie das ist eine
Herausforderung für uns alle erwarten
uns im Herbst extremwahlen also
tatsächlich ein politbeben was wollen
die ampelparteien und die CDU dagegen
unternehmen gibt es überhaupt ein
Gegenmittel und welche Rolle spielt
Sarah Wagenknecht das schauen wir uns
jetzt genau an bei inside
[Applaus]
politics kurz zur Ausgangslage am 1
September wird in Sachsen und Thüringen
gewählt am 22 September dann in
Brandenburg in den aktuellen Umfragen
liegt die AFD bei allen drei Wahlen
vorne jeweils etwa jeder dritte gibt an
dass er sein Kreuz aktuell bei der AFD
machen würde die AFD Landesverbände in
Sachsen und Thüringen werden vom
Verfassungsschutz als gesichert
rechtsextremistisch eingestuft der
Verfassungsschutz ist hier also zu der
Erkenntnis gekommen dass die Partei
verfassungsfeindliche Position vertritt
die sich gegen die Menschenwürde das
Demokratie und das Rechtsstaatsprinzip
wenden in Thüringen ist der Spitzen
Kandidat Björn höcke höcke den man
gerichtsfest als Faschisten bezeichnen
darf weil das eben auf überprüfbaren
tatsachengrundlagen fußst wenn man
allerdings zu Wahlveranstaltung von
höcke geht sieht man dass das viele
einfach gar nicht mehr abschreckt weil
es in unserem Lande chaotisch zugeht und
es muss ich ändern außerdem bin ich
wahrscheinlich der größte Fan von Pen
Hecke so wie es jetzt
ist beobachte schon seit Jahren dieser
Sumpf das muss ein haben weil einfach
die die Menschen unzufrieden sind und
weil die deutsche weil weil wir Deutsche
eigentlich bisschen ja nicht mehr so in
Vordergrund gestellt werden ja was meint
ihr woher kommt diese Wut und könnt ihr
sie verstehen oder seid ihr eher wütend
auf die wütenden schreibt das gerne in
die Kommentare sooviel jetzt zu den
aktuellen Aussichten der AFD jetzt
stellt sich die Frage welche Partei kann
da noch dagegen halten der SPD droht vor
allem in Thüringen und Sachsen ein
ziemliches debarkel es scheint sogar
möglich dass sie es nicht nicht über die
5% Hürde schafft das wäre dann das erste
Mal dass die SPD nicht mehr den
Wiedereinzug in einen Landtag schafft
die FDP würde nach aktuellen Umfragen in
keinen der drei Landtage kommen die
Grünen Ligen bei jeweils 5 bis 8%. ja
die CDU steht in Umfragen gerade jeweils
nicht schlechter aber eben trotzdem
hinter der AFD vor 5 Jahren hat es in
den drei Ländern jeweils für den
amtierenden Ministerpräsidenten gereicht
wenn auch knapp also SPD man Wutke in
Brandenburg CDU Mann kretschm in Sachsen
und der linke Bodo rammelo in Thüringen
das waren damals harte aufreibende
Wahlkämpfe und diesmal ist die
Ausgangslage ja noch
[Musik]
schwieriger ja und dann ist da noch ein
Faktor der diese Wahlen noch
unberechenbarer macht die gerade
gegründete Partei von Sarah Wagenknecht
im aktuellen Politbarometer gibt es für
diese Partei erstaunlich hohe
Zustimmungswerte 21% geben an dass sie
das Bündnis sarer wenknecht bei einer
Bundestagswahl sicher oder
wahrscheinlich wählen würden das sagen
unter anderem mehr als die Hälfte der
Anhänger der Linkspartei und mehr als
ein Drittel der Anhänger der AFD auch in
den Umfragen zu den Landtagswahlen steht
die wagenknechtpartei ähnlich gut da und
das obwohl es weder Kandidaten noch
Programm gibt es reicht die Ankündigung
und der Frust über die anderen es sieht
also tatsächlich nach einem ziemlichen
wahlbeben aus im Herbst was aber wollen
die ampelparteien und die CDU
Unternehmen damit es nicht seit
[Musik]
kommt auf den Demonstration in diesen
Wochen wird vielfach gefordert man müsse
die AFD verbieten es gebe genügend
Beweise für eine aktiv kämpferische
aggressive Haltung gegenüber der
demokratischen Grundordnung so hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht mal definiert
was für ein Parteiverbot nötig wäre wenn
das Gericht also bei der AFD eine
verfassungsfeindliche Haltung erkennt
die sie auch aggressiv umsetzen will
dann könnte die Partei verboten werden
oft ist diese Forderung mit der Hoffnung
verknüpft dass ein Verbot dann auch
Auswirkung hätte auf die ostwahlen im
Herbst warum war das aber nicht so ist
und warum ein solches Verbotsverfahren
generell ziemlich schwierig ist dazu
gibt es von meiner Kollegin Christian
hübscher eine eigene Folge von Inside
politics hier oben rechts haben wir die
mal für euch verlinkt ja neben der
Verbotsdebatte hört man jetzt aber auch
sehr häufig man müsse die AFD inhaltlich
stellen auch und gerade in den
Wahlkämpfen im Herbst also ich halte es
für ganz wichtig dass wir die AFD vor
allen Dinge mit politischen Mitteln
bekämpfen dass wir sie auch hinter Sache
stellen ich will diese politische
Auseinandersetzung mit der AFD
führen die AFD gibt oft einfache aber
falsche Antworten und genau diese
Auseinandersetzung in der Sache muss man
suchen man muss entlarfen was dort
politisch gewollt ist ich rate dringend
dazu die Debatte mit der AFD politisch
zu führen politisch muss man diese
Auseinandersetzung gewinnen wollen und
auch überzeugend gewinnen das ist jetzt
der Auftrag an alle so spannt ist die
CDU hat da gerade einen bemerkenswerten
Strategiewechsel hingelegt bislang war
die Grundhaltung eher bloß nicht so viel
Aufmerksamkeit für die AFD sie nicht
größer machen als sie ist jetzt auch mit
Blick auf die jüngsten Enthüllungen
setzt die CDU stattdessen auf aktives
dagegenhalten wir werden in diese Wahlen
gehen mit einer sehr klaren sehr harten
Auseinandersetzung insbesondere gegen
die AFD der Opfermythos der AFD der muss
ein Ende haben wir machen die nicht zu
metüren diese angebliche alternative
höcke muss ins Licht gezogen werden weil
dann wird nämlich auch seine ganze
Schwäche offenbar ja und das wird schon
richtig konkret Mario Vogt den ihr
gerade gehört und gesehen habt ist der
CDU Landesvorsitzende und CDU
Spitzenkandidat in Thüringen und der
wird demnächst mit Björn höcke ein
öffentliches Streitgespräch zum Thema
Europa führen vor einigen Monaten noch
wäre das kaum denkbar gewesen da hätte
man Björn höcke nicht die Bühne geben
wollen und erst recht nicht auf
derselben Bühne mit ihm stehen wollen
jetzt aber findet das statt was meint
ihr ist das richtig mit börn höcke
diskutieren oder ist das genau der
falsche Weg schreibt uns eure Meinung
gerne in die Kommentare falsch
verersprechen wie Widersprüche und
Lehrstellen der AFD sollen jetzt also
aktiv benannt und aufgezeigt werden
außerdem hat Friedrich märz die CDU
Partei Prominenz aufgefordert sie sollen
im Osten ganz aktiv Wahlkampf machen
übrigens was die AFD von diesem
inhaltlich Stellen hält hat mir der Vize
Fraktionsvorsitzende der AFD in
Brandenburg neulich sehr deutlich in die
Kamera gesagt D sollen sie uns doch
stellen wir hatten damals die
Möglichkeit uns 14 15 wo sie angefangen
haben die Frasen rauszuhauen wir müssen
sie stellen da Sie die Chance wo war
zusammwürfelte hfen waren jetzt nach 10
Jahren wird's natürlich immer schlechter
für die anderen weil wir sind jetzt
angekommen wir werden noch bleiben es
bleibt aber die Frage geht das denn
dieses inhitlich Stellen ist das
erfolgversprechend oder hat das auch
Grenzen vor kurzem haben wir den
Innenminister von Thüringen begleitet
Georg Meyer das ist ein SPD-Mann und der
hat jetzt schon seine ersten
Wahlkampfveranstaltung gemacht tja und
sein etwas deprimierender Befund war so
richtig kommt er mittlerweile gar nicht
mehr ins Gespräch die AFD sei eben
Demokratie zersetzend mit Debatten über
ihren Inhalt dringt er gar nicht mehr
durch die AFD behauptet ja gerade hier
in Ostdeutschland sie ist das Sprachrohr
der Menschen im Osten sie ist die Partei
des Ostens wenn man genau reinschaut in
das Parteiprogramm der AFD was will sie
denn sie will die Erbschaftssteuer
abschaffen wenn die Erbschaftssteuer
abgeschafft wird dann profitiert vor
allen Dingen profitieren vor allen
Dingen vermögende im Westen das sage ich
immer und immer wieder aber es
interessiert viele Leute gar nicht auch
expert die sich mit dem Auftreten und
den Plänen der AFD z.B in Thüringen
beschäftigen zweifeln daran ob
inhaltlich Stellen wirklich funktioniert
die Gefahr die sie sehen am Ende könnte
das nur trügerische Selbstberuhigung
sein also ich weiß nicht genau was damit
gemeint sein soll die AFD inhaltlich zu
stellen wäre die AFD eine Partei um
deren Inhalte man sich genauso mit ihr
auseinandersetzen kann wie mit jeder
anderen Partei auch dann wäre die AFD
sowieso kein Problem dann wäre sie ja
tatsächlich einfach nur die konservative
Partei die sie zu sein vorgibt aber das
ist halt nicht der Fall in Berlin von
Vertretern der Regierungsparteien hört
man gerade oft man habe es jetzt ja
wirklich verstanden durch den
öffentlichen Dauerstreit der letzten
Jahre sei viel Vertrauen verloren
gegangen auch das sei eine Ursache für
die schlechten Aussichten bei den Wahlen
im Herbst jetzt aber wollle man vor
diesen schwierigen Wahlen Einigkeit
demonstrieren es kostet vertrauen wenn
immer alle sagen wir machen das jetzt
besser wir machen es jetzt anders und
dann trotzdem alles weitergeht wie
bisher weniger öffentlich zu streiten
das darf kein neujahrsvor bleiben
sondern es muss endlich Realität werden
die Grünen übrigens so hören wir das in
Hintergrundgesprächen wollen jetzt mit
Blick auf die ostwahlen vor allem auf
soziale Themen setzen das sei ihr Rezept
gegen die Wut die sie dort wahrnehmen ja
das sind wie gesagt Vorhaben und die
Beteuerung im Moment allerdings spricht
auch vieles dafür dass das gemeinsame
Regieren in der Ampel echt nicht
einfacher wird für soziale Wohltaten ist
kaum Geld da und die nächste C
Auseinandersetzung die lässt sicher
nicht lange auf sich warten z.B beim
Kinder oder beim Klima Geld ja die
Wahlkämpfer der ampelparteien in Sachsen
Brandenburg und Thüringen jedenfalls
machen kein Hel daraus dass Berlin
gerade nervt das ist also die Lage vor
den Wahlen im Herbst aber wie sieht's
eigentlich danach
[Musik]
aus eine Frage wird sicher spannt ab dem
ersten Tag nach den Wahlen wer koaliert
jetzt mit wem tatsächlich ist die
Mehrheitsfindung in den ostdeutschen
Bundesländern wahnsinnig kompliziert
eine Koalition mit der AFD haben alle
anderen Parteien kategorisch
ausgeschlossen für die CDU gilt auch ein
Beschluss dass es keine Koalition mit
der Linkspartei geben soll ja und ganz
grundsätzlich stellt sich auch die Frage
ob so etwas wie eine
Allparteienkoalition also alle gegen die
AFD wirklich sinnvoll wäre das würde
könnte man sagen die Erzählung bedienen
die die AFD gern verbreitet dass alle
anderen so nah beieinander wären und sie
die einzige angebliche alternative so
eine überraschende Rolle könnte da die
Partei von Sarah Wagenknecht spielen die
ersten spekulieren schon ob am Ende sie
z.B für die Union in Thüringen eine
mehrheitss sicher hat das muss man sich
d mal vorstellen der konservative
Friedrich März der heimlich auf die
ehemalige Kommunistin Sarah Wagenknecht
hofft auch das wäre dann so etwas wie
ein politbeben nur anders als
ursprünglich gedacht das war unser Blick
auf das was da im September kommen
könnte wir freuen uns über eure
Kommentare und auch über Themenwünsche
was interessiert euch für unser inside
politics die Folge zum Thema AFD
Verbotsverfahren findet ihr hier neben
mir die kann ich euch zu dem Thema
wirklich sehr empfehlen und wenn ihr bei
inside politics immer auf dem Lauf
bleiben wollt Abonniert gern unseren
Kanal